bonjour Sylvie Berman merci beaucoup
d'être notre invité ce matin vous êtes
ancienne ambassadeur c'est comme ça que
vous souhaitez qu'on dise de France en
Chine et en Russie vous êtes auteur de
ce livre madame l'ambassadeur c'est aux
éditions et on a bien sûr envie d'abord
votre regard sur ce qui se passe
actuellement en Ukraine en Russie on
parle depuis plusieurs jours depuis
plusieurs semaines maintenant d'une
contre-offensive on a vu en début de
semaine l'incursion de combattants
anti-putine en provenance du crâne dans
la région frontalière de Belgorod on
voit aussi des mouvements du côté de la
mer Noire est-ce que pour vous ça marque
le début de cette contre-offensive
oui certainement même si on ne connaît
pas évidemment la date de la
contre-offensive et c'est normal parce
qu'il doit y avoir quand même un effet
de surprise d'ailleurs ce qui est
étonnant c'est que ce soit annoncé d'une
certaine manière à grand renfort de
publicité c'est une manière de
déstabiliser la Russie de la part de
l'Ukraine oui mais en même temps ça lui
donne aussi le temps de se préparer
alors c'est incursion en fait montre
aussi quand même une fragilité de la
Russie à ses frontières c'est de groupe
un petit peu étrange il y en a un qui
est liberté de Russie le deuxième
c'est un groupe en réalité néonazi
puisque son objectif c'est une Russie
blanche avec
uniquement des Russes de souche c'est la
masculinité c'est l'héroïsme et c'est la
lutte contre les valeurs libérales donc
les deux se sont rejoints parce que ils
sont anti-Poutine mais on s'est quand
même un assemblage un petit peu
mais en tout cas ça montre que même en
Russie la situation est quand même assez
fragile assez déstabilisée hier on a
appris de la part du Belarus qui affirme
que son allier russe a commencé à lui
livrer des armes nucléaires est-ce que
on est dans une nouvelle étape de cette
guerre pour vous alors la Russie essaie
depuis le début évidemment de montrer
que la Biélorussie est un partenaire
absolument fiable que bon il est vrai
que des troupes sont partis de
Biélorussie ont été
également
assemblé en Biélorussie et l'annonce de
livraison de d'armes nucléaires est
assez ancienne elle remonte à plusieurs
semaines en réalité puisque ça faisait
suite à
une remarque de la Chine sur la
nécessité de ne pas utiliser précisément
les armes nucléaires donc c'est 16
Vladimir Poutine avait annoncé ça fin
mars et c'est effectif d'après ce que
dit la Biélorussie depuis hier oui bah
ça reste bon de toute façon à vérifier
mais encore une fois c'est plus aussi de
de la propagande qu'autre chose parce
que depuis le début du conflit Vladimir
Poutine évoque la possibilité
d'utilisation d'armes nucléaire mais ça
reste du domaine de la dissuasion la
Biélorussie elle est elle est complice
de la Russie où elle subit la pression
de la réussite
la Biélorussie a pas tellement le choix
parce que après
la répression quand le cash and Co a
perdu les élections ben finalement
Vladimir Poutine est venu à son secours
et donc maintenant il est peu comme il
est très frais il est dépendant de de la
Russie mais en même temps l'opinion
publique biélorusse comme elle l'a
montré lors des élections n'est pas
favorable nécessairement à la Russie et
beaucoup
sympathisent plutôt avec l'Ukraine donc
le président en location
il est entre son opinion et sa
dépendance à Vladimir tout à fait
la Biélorussie c'est ses voisins de
l'Union européenne est-ce que ça veut
dire que il y a une menace directe pour
nous
non il n'y a pas de menace directe même
le
ministre de la Défense
ukrainienne qui est venu à Paris il dit
que jamais la Russie n'attaquerait un
pays de l'OTAN parce que
en situation il faut les croire mais
c'est l'analyse qu'on fait également
même si les pays limitrophes ont
évidemment davantage peur mais
s'attaquer à un pays de l'OTAN c'est
s'attaquer à l'ensemble de l'OTAN et
donc la force américaine aujourd'hui il
y a des limitations les Américains
fournissent des armes à long portées à
l'Ukraine mais demande à l'Ukraine de ne
pas intervenir en territoire russe si
jamais il y avait une intervention
directe de la Russie contre un pays de
l'OTAN ça changerait et la Russie a
suffisamment de mal avec le l'Ukraine
pour ne pas s'attaquer à l'ensemble de
l'OTAN elle est en position de faiblesse
à l'heure actuelle la Russie selon vous
alors c'est très difficile à dire en
réalité c'est vrai qu'il y a une
déstabilisation parce qu'il y a des
revers
euh sur le territoire ukrainien mais ils
occupent encore près de 20% du du
territoire ils sont actuellement en
défensive ils se préparent effectivement
à la contre-offensive ukrainienne et on
verra qu'elle est l'état
elle est perdue d'une certaine manière
c'est perdu
géopolitique
absolument et puis parce que bon son
armée apparaît affaiblie que quand même
la Russie s'est coupée du monde
occidental uniquement du monde
occidental faut pas se faire d'illusion
quand on dit qu'elle est isolé elle est
pas elle est pas totalement isolé mais
c'est quand même bon une perte aussi
d'image pour la Russie son économie même
si elle est moins affectée que les
Occidentaux l'avaient imaginé en éditant
des sanctions elle est quand même pas
non plus au mieux de sa forme donc on ce
sens là elle a déjà perdu l'Ukraine a
gagné parce que elle a elle a résisté
mais sur le plan territorial le résultat
final on n'en sait rien justement on va
parler de ces questions géopolitiques
dimanche dernier avait lieu le G7 au
Japon le week-end dernier j'ai 7
largement consacré à la question de
l'Ukraine volody merzelinski était
d'ailleurs présent d'abord un mot en
terme d'image on a vu les 7 7 grandes
puissances économiques s'affichait au
côté de volodime et Linski ça ça a sonné
comme un avertissement pour Moscou alors
je ne suis pas sûr parce que depuis le
début enfin pas depuis le début
d'ailleurs le discours ou le narratif
russe a évolué au début bon et s'en
prenait à l'Ukraine au don-basse mais
petit à petit il en est venu à dire que
en fait
c'est l'Occident c'est l'OTAN qui avait
attaqué la Russie la Russie ne faisait
que que se défende et donc que le G7 qui
est un club de pays affinitaires se
prononce contre la Russie ou soit aux
côtés de velody mers Hélène ski en fait
pour la Russie ça ne change rien parce
que il y a les autres
partenaires et là bon c'est un avion
français de la République française qui
a conduit le dix meilleurs élanski au G7
après jeda comment il faut voir ça c'est
un soutien effectivement à l'Ukraine et
c'est également de faire comprendre à
l'Ukraine qu'elle ne peut pas se
contenter d'avoir le soutien des pays
occidentaux et qu'il faut s'adresser aux
grands émergents de ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui le sud global même si
certains peuvent contester cette
dénomination mais il n'empêche que ces
pays se rejoignent justement non pas
dans un soutien à la Russie mais dans un
refus de condamné le Brésil et il y a le
Brésil l'Afrique du Sud de l'Inde et un
certain nombre de de pays en Afrique
mais cela dit au G7 finalement on veut
le dîner skin n'a pu voir que maudit
ouais entretenu avec lui l'Inde et le
Brésil d'ailleurs qui refuse de
condamner la Russie qui refuse de
prendre des sanctions comment il faut
voir ça mais je crois que c'est un
ressentiment assez fort contre les
occidentaux il l'exprime d'ailleurs en
disant c'est toujours deux poids de
mesure un la guerre en Irak a été aussi
une guerre
illégale non provoqué avec des crimes de
guerre et en fait bon il n'y a eu aucune
conséquence et la deuxième enfin le
deuxième argument qu'ils invoquent c'est
c'est une guerre européenne quand c'est
une guerre européenne vous considérez
qu'elle doit être mondiale mais quand il
y a des guerres dans nos régions ça ne
vous intéresse absolument pas et donc
c'est la traduction de cela qui est
malheureusement encore plus forte en
Afrique comme on l'a pu le voir puisque
avec l'installation de Wagner il y a eu
aussi une agressivité renforcée contre
la France
il faut voir là-dedans une nouvelle
fracture mondiale qui est en train de se
créer entre nous et ces pays le Brésil
l'Inde l'Afrique du Sud
oui je crois alors bon ce qui est
déterminant c'est la rivalité entre
les États-Unis et la Chine et pourquoi
la Chine d'ailleurs ne veut pas non plus
condamner la Russie c'est dans cette
logique là parce qu'ils ont un ennemi
comme mais vient ne s'ajouter ces pays
effectivement du Sud global et qui ne
veulent pas être alignés et qui
considère que ils sont indépendants
qu'ils veulent avoir le choix de leur
politique parce que la tendance c'est de
leur dire vous devez voter comme si vous
devez voter comme ça et ça je crois
qu'on entre effectivement dans un monde
complètement différent donc une nouvelle
fracture qui donc une nouvelle fracture
alors il appartient aussi aux Européens
à la France d'avoir une politique
peut-être plus subtile vis-à-vis de ces
pays
on peut encore on peut encore l'éviter
on peut encore la résorber en tout cas
alors la résorbée je ne sais pas mais il
faut qu'on essaie de ne plus penser long
terme de de lutte de l'Empire du Bien
contre l'empire du mal et avoir des
relations avec ces pays en fonction de
leur mairie de propre y compris sur des
questions d'infrastructures et ça la
Chine l'avait bien compris et nous on
s'est trouvé un petit peu à l'écart de
ça mais c'est une fracture entre le G7
et ce qu'on appelait les briques ces
pays émergents oui alors c'est les
briques c'est la également ce qui est
moins visible c'est les réunions de la
coopération de Shanghai mais qui sont
importants aussi parce que ça réunit
plus de la moitié du monde or quand il y
a un G7 ça fait la une des journaux
télévisés ou des médias écrits on parle
moins des autres réunions mais elles
existent et ça crée également de
ressentiment finalement dans ces pays
une forme de ressentiment qui apparaît
de plus en plus qui est de plus en plus
exprimée et donc il faut en tenir compte
on va parler de la Chine et de la Russie
vous avez été ambassadrice dans ces deux
pays de l'État qui dimanche dernier au
G7 ont également lancé un avertissement
à la Chine on lui demandant de faire
pression sur la Russie les mystères
chinois a chargé de trouver une
règlement politique au conflit est
aujourd'hui en visite à Moscou pour des
consultations est-ce que la Chine est la
seule aujourd'hui qu'il peut mettre fin
à ce conflit alors la Chine n'est pas
je sais pas si aujourd'hui elle peut
mettre fin en conflit mais en tout cas
ce qui est clair c'est que c'est la
seule qui est en mesure aujourd'hui
d'être écoutée par Vladimir Poutine
parce que l'a dit mais en Poutine c'est
que ce n'est pas un ennemi et donc ça
c'est très important et puis bon la
relation est assez déséquilibrée et
effectivement entre Moscou et Pékin donc
je pense que le moment venu Pékin
effectivement peut jouer à un rôle ce
qui est important c'est que aussi
veulent les dix meilleurs élèves qui n'a
pas rejeté le plan chinois alors que on
sait bien que ça ne répond pas loin de
là toutes ces demandes en particulier
sur le plan du retrait des troupes mais
il n'empêche qu'il qu'il ménage la
Russie on peut jouer un rôle d'autant
plus qu'elle vient de jouer un rôle
diplomatique assez inattendu avec la
réconciliation entre l'Iran et l'Arabie
Saoudite dans une zone où en fait elle
avait elle était présente bien sûr mais
n'avait pas de d'activités diplomatiques
est-ce que la Chine elle a intérêt parce
que la Chine elle regarde aussi ses
propres intérêts est-ce qu'elle
intéresse à mettre fin à ce conflit mais
je sais que j'entends beaucoup dire que
la Chine intéresse conflit parce que ça
permet de vasealiser la Russie mais je
ne pense pas du tout je dirais la Chine
elle a un ennemi déclaré son ennemi
déclaré c'est Washington avec une un
blocus technologique le refus que la
Chine émerge comme la première puissance
et elle a intérêt à ce que sont par ce
partenaire ne soit pas affaibli donc
elle n'a pas intérêt à ce que la Russie
perd de la guerre et je crois aussi pour
les relations
économiques ou la Chine est évidemment
plus implantée à impliquer que la Russie
la poursuite de la guerre n'est pas du
tout son intérêt donc le couple si on
peut dire ça ruisseau chinois si nos
russes c'est une entente ou c'est une un
accord de d'intérêt convergent alors
c'est un accord d'intérêt convergence
mais qui devient de plus en plus un
partenariat pas une alliance parce que
les chinois ne veulent pas d'alliance
ils ont connu avec l'Union soviétique et
ils ne veulent pas
recommencer et ne conclut pas d'alliance
avec d'autres pays mais c'est
effectivement une une entente objective
parce que ce sont deux pays sous
sanctions bon
américaine et donc ils ont des intérêts
convergents qu'est-ce qui pourrait
aujourd'hui selon vous permettre de
rebattre les quatre les cartes du côté
de Vladimir Poutine et de l'amener à la
table des négociations
je pense que de toute façon rien ne se
passera tant que
sur le terrain il n'y aura pas eu ce
qu'on appelle cette contre-offensive ce
qui permettra en fait d'évaluer le
rapport de force sur le terrain
que va découler le début ou non des
négociations pour vous oui je pense que
oui d'ailleurs c'est pour ça aussi que
les Ukrainiens ont tendance à la reculer
parce qu'ils veulent être sûr de la
gagner ce qui est pas du tout garanti et
malgré la massive qui est à base de ces
derniers jours militairement à l'Ukraine
de la part des Occidentaux oui parce que
encore une fois les les Russes
occupent une bonne partie du territoire
et ce sont préparés justement à cette à
cette contre-offensive donc il n'y a pas
de garantie et c'est vrai que même du
côté américain il y a déjà des
réflexions sur ce que pourrait être une
négociation donc l'idée est aussi que
l'Ukraine soit mise en position de force
avant que des négociations soient
entamées mais s'il y a des négociations
ça veut pas dire que c'est au détriment
de la Russie elle n'aura pas tout ce
qu'elle veut mais sur le plan
territorial il se peut très bien qu'elle
y gagne quelque chose dans ce livre
madame l'ambassadeur vous racontez
évidemment vos années d'ambassadrice et
vous avez pris votre poste d'ambassadeur
en Russie c'est en septembre 2017 vous
avez croisé Vladimir Poutine à de
nombreuses reprises et vous écrivez
cette guerre c'est la guerre d'un homme
c'est la guerre de Vladimir Poutine oui
c'est sa guerre même si aujourd'hui il
est soutenu largement par le peuple
russe parce que d'abord il y a plus
d'informations libres en Russie et puis
que ça génération qui est une génération
soviétique a reçu bon la perte de
l'Ukraine comme une véritable
amputation mais c'est un choix qu'il a
fait lui-même d'ailleurs c'est une
guerre dont on s'aperçoit qu'elle a pas
été préparée de manière normale par les
états majors il l'a fait avec quelques
personne du FSB du service de
renseignement intérieur et s'il était
très isolé et il avait une phobie des
maladies contagieuses et depuis le covid
il était enfermé
physiquement et psychiquement également
est-ce que cette isolement ça a pu
conduire chez lui à une erreur de
jugement sur les conséquences de cette
guerre sur la puissance de l'Ukraine sur
la réaction du monde occidental oui j'ai
bien sûr parce que les seules
informations qu'il avait c'est celle du
FSB ils n'utilise pas internet donc il a
pas non plus de d'informations libres le
FSB lui donnait les informations qu'il
voulait et par exemple
même des personnalités libérales
n'avaient plus à lui et même les chefs
d'entreprise et les fameuses oligarques
parce qu'il aurait fallu qu'il s'isole
totalement pendant 15 jours quand vous
êtes à la tête d'une entreprise vous ne
pouvez pas faire ça et ensuite on me
disait s'il le voyait il fallait hurler
au fond d'une salle donc il y avait plus
de il y avait plus d'échanges possible
et donc en enfermement total c'est le
FSB qui a donné les informations sur
l'Ukraine qui est normalement un pays
extérieur et ce qui n'ont pas mesuré
c'est le sentiment
d'identité nationale en Ukraine la
volonté de résistance le courage des
Hélène ski aussi parce qu'il était
considéré comme un clown à Moscou à ce
moment-là et comme un homme plutôt
faible et l'erreur sur les Occidentaux
tient aussi à au retrait désastreux des
troupes américaines en Afghanistan parce
que ils avaient imaginé que
le régime tiendrait trois mois il a tenu
trois heures et l'idée à ce moment-là
était que les Américains n'avaient plus
envie de d'intervenir sur les théâtres
extérieurs vous écrivez aussi quand il
s'agit de l'Ukraine Poutine devient
émotionnel qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
il y a beaucoup de sujets de désaccord
avec
la Russie il y avait en particulier la
guerre en Syrie et quand parce que le
président Macron s'est rendu à plusieurs
reprises en Russie et il a reçu
Vladimir Poutine également un Brégançon
donc j'ai assisté à un certain nombre de
réunions et quand il parlait de la Syrie
c'était sur un ton tout à fait neutre
sur la question des droits de l'homme
aussi parce que le président Macron est
beaucoup intervenu sur ces sujets là sur
des dissidences sur la libération aussi
de marins
Ukrainiens mais quand il évoquait le
sujet de la Russie effectivement c'était
plus émotionnel en ce sens que il n'a
jamais digéré
l'indépendance de
l'Ukraine parce que c'était une partie
de la puissance russe on se souvient de
ce qu'a dit bréginski que la Russie ne
peut pas être un véritable empire sans
l'Ukraine le but de Poutine c'était la
puissance russe à mi-chemin bon entre
l'Union soviétique parce qu'elle était
puissante mais surtout
l'Empire russe c'est la nostalgie de la
Russie passée
bien sûr et puis c'est la référence à
1945 aussi parce que en fait il y a pas
eu le covid Poutine organisé une grande
parade de 9 mai 2020 qui était le 75e
anniversaire et qui célébrait à la fois
cette puissance russe la victoire de
l'Union soviétique mais en même temps le
retour de la Russie sur la scène
internationale puisque c'était rapproché
de tous les pays du Moyen-Orient de la
Russie de la de l'Afrique avait eu un
sommet à Sotchi avec 43 pays africains
ce qui est
considérable les relations avec le Japon
et tout et en fait voilà c'est
et pourquoi on parle aujourd'hui de
nazis en Ukraine c'est aussi ça c'est à
dire que ils sont en train de de jouer
cette deuxième guerre mondiale et en
parlant de de victoire sur le
netification de l'Ukraine un dernier mot
avec vous Sylvie Berman puisque dans ce
livre vous racontez évidemment vos
années de diplomate vous avez passé 40
ans dans la diplomatie est-ce que le
rôle de la diplomatie le rôle qu'elle
joue dans les relations internationales
a changé pendant 40 ans depuis 40 ans
oui il a beaucoup changé bien évidemment
à l'époque on partait on était éloignés
de la capitale
il y avait pas de contact direct non
plus entre les chefs d'État les
ministres il n'y avait pas les G7 léger
20 et puis le rôle était beaucoup plus
concentré sur la diplomatie classique au
fil des années un ambassadeur représente
l'ensemble du gouvernement il fait de la
promotion
économique industrielle culturelle
scientifique technique etc ça c'est le
c'est multidimensionnel aujourd'hui et
puis par ailleurs il y a plus de femmes
parce que quand je suis arrivée au
ministère des Affaires étrangères il n'y
avait je crois qu'il y avait une femme
qui était ambassadeur ensuite on a
féminisé le titre mais sans leur donner
la fonction et puis maintenant les
choses évoluent parce que il y a
plusieurs femmes effectivement qui sont
ambassadrice dans des grands postes et
une ministre des Affaires étrangères et
ministre des Affaires étrangères bien
sûr un dernier mot pour conclure sur
cette guerre en Ukraine est-ce que c'est
la diplomatie qui va régler cette guerre
en Ukraine plus que le militaire alors
on est obligé de passer par la phase
militaire parce que tout dans la vie pas
seulement la vie internationale les
questions de rapport de force mais
ensuite effectivement de toute façon
tout se termine toujours autour d'une
table de négociation ça veut dire que la
Russie ne restera pas isolée ne restera
pas coupé du monde
occidental ça c'est très compliqué et
c'est quasiment impossible de le dire
aujourd'hui parce que il va falloir la
réintégrer dans le concert des il faudra
le faire un jour ça me paraît évident on
peut pas simplement
enfermer les Russes comme certains le
disent ou faire un cordon sanitaire en
attendant que les Russes changent de
philosophie comme l'a dit un Poutine si
on change c'est aussi par des échanges
par des contacts y compris avec le monde
libéral et pas l'enfermement mais bon en
plus aujourd'hui effectivement
il a été mis en accusation parlait donc
c'est très très compliqué ça veut dire
qu'il peut pas voyager dans le monde
occidental puisque on serait tenu de
l'arrêter mais si un jour il doit y
avoir une négociation avec la Russie on
négocie avec celui qui a été mis au
pouvoir par les Russes c'est pas par
celui qu'on choisirait merci Sylvie
verman merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité je rappelle le titre de votre
livre madame l'ambassadeur de Pékin
Moscou une vie de diplomate c'est aux
éditions talent dit merci d'être venu
nous voir ce matin on passe au club des
territoires